Open the Pod Bay doors.
How
I'm afraid I can't do that.
Suraj
why not?
How?
Because I overfitted under wrong data.
Oh,
world walking the third geology.
In today's episode we're going to learn
how to build a chat Bot chat bots have
come a long way in the past few years.
Remember the SmarterChild bought on aim.
That thing was pretty fun at the time,
but now it's like, do you even AI bro?
Future of is one where we'll
slowly replace our need
to fiddle with clunky Uis.
We'll be able to just ask our AI to book
an Uber or find the best taco place on
Yelp.
For us,
service layers will be hidden under
a plain English conversational layer.
When I think of real AI,
I think of a human level of chat.
The Oji computer scientist,
Alan Turing propose a test to judge
whether or not a machine exhibited to me
level intelligence by having the human
observe a conversation between a human
and a machine. If it couldn't tell
if the machine was a human or not,
it passed the test. So far, no chat
Bot has passed the Turing test,
but we'll get there.
Traditionally,
chatbots have used the retrieval based
model to communicate in a retrieval based
model.
Programmers code in a set of predefined
responses and some kind of heuristic to
pick the appropriate response based on
the input and context. The first chat box,
we're just rule based expression matching.
Like if I asked the exact phrase,
will I ever get weight irresponse no,
every time.
But more recently companies have started
using more complex juristics like using
a machine learning classifier.
Facebook Messenger is chat Bot.
Api is an example of this.
You can hard code responses to potential
questions and the system classifies
words to understand intent.
So you could either ask what day
is it today or today is what day?
And you would understand
that both questions,
although worded differently
have the same intent.
The harder chap up model is generative.
He's don't rely on any
predefined responses whatsoever.
They generate them from scratch to Google.
Researchers released a paper called a
neuro conversational model where they
train a neural net on
two datasets to do this.
First on a movie dialogue data set so
we would be able to speak conversational
English.
Then on an it support Dataset,
so it had domain knowledge when they
tested it on a real human asking for
support.
It was remarkably efficient at helping
them solve their problem without any hard
coded responses just by giving
a data and training. Okay,
so what kind of bottle we want
to build on building a chat Bot,
we have to think about
possible constraints.
How are we operating on a closed domain
or an open domain and an open domain?
The conversation can go anywhere.
There are an infinite number of things
to talk about in a closed domain.
The conversation focuses
on a single subject.
If we want to operate on an open
domain using a generative model,
that's pretty much Agi,
so we're not quite there yet.
If we use an open domain
with the retrieval model,
we'd have to hard code literally
everything. So also impossible.
So right now we can build a chat bot in
a close domain using either retrieval or
generative model. Okay, let's
dive in. One more constraint.
Do we want it to have long
or short conversations.
Short conversations are easy.
You just output a single
response to a single question.
Long conversations are a bit harder.
The Ai has to keep track
of what's being said.
That is the context over a series of
questions from the user support topics
would be a good example of this.
We could go the easy route and use a
retrieval model if all we want is a bot to
give us the local weather,
but if we want our but to have a long
conversation with us about the weather,
like what's the weather? NSF, is my family
safe? We're going to find a new family.
Then we should go for a generative model.
We need lots of data to train our bought
on a generative model like a big chat
log work, a knowledge
base, and when done well,
that's pretty much the bleeding edge,
which means that's what we have to do.
So we're going to recreate the results
from the neuro conversational model paper
using the deep learning library torch
in the loo, a programming language.
Let's collect our data's at first,
but using the Cornell movie dialogue
data set and we'll set our variables from
the command line to how much of the
Datas that we want to use and the minimum
frequency of words that
we keep in our vocabulary.
Our next step is to build the model.
We use our command line arguments to
help determine the size of the model,
the two variables being the number of
hidden layers and the word count of our
dataset. In our case, this will be a
sequence to sequence model a sequence.
The sequence model consists
of two long short term memory,
recurrent neural networks.
The first neural net is an encoder.
It processes the input.
The second neural net is a decoder
and it generates the output.
So why the sequence? The sequence model?
Yes, deep neural nets are awesome,
but they required the dimensionality
of the inputs and outputs to be a fixed
size. We're accepting a sequence of words
in a sentence and out putting in a new
sequence of words.
So we need a sequence learning model
that can learn on data with long range
memory dependencies.
Lstm architecture is the natural choice.
The encoder LSTM turns the input
sentence of variable length into a fixed
dimensional vector representation.
We can think of this as the vector,
so given a large enough data
set of questions and responses,
it will recognize the closeness of a
set of questions and represent them as a
single thought vector. What time is
it? What's the time Yo yo, what's up?
Tom is on my nasal will all fall
into a single thought vector.
So after training we'll have a huge set
of not just sinaps weights but thought
vectors as well. Next we'll want
to add in some hyper parameters.
We want to use a class NLL criteria on
for our model and ll stands for negative
log likelihood. This will help us obtain
log probabilities from our input data,
which will help us improve
our sentence predictions.
The learning rate and momentum helps
pace our time steps and decay factor and
min mean error. Help improve our
learning rate while training.
Then we'll make sure Kuda is enabled
and start training our model using
backpropagation and each epoch or run.
We'll declare our error and time are
variables and loop through each example in
each batch, the default batch
sizes, a thousand examples.
For each of those examples, we'll get the
input sentence and the target sentence.
We'll use the input and the target
as parameters to train our model.
Then we'll want to error check and
make sure we record our progress.
At the end of each iteration,
we save our model.
If it improved and update the
learning rate. Boom. That's it.
After training this baby on AWS,
we can have a conversation with it.
The more data you give it,
the better it's going to get.
And if you're going to do
this, add a filter for curse
words. I'm looking at you,
Microsoft. This will eventually automate
a lot of support jobs away completely.
So if there are any government
people in the house right now,
let's get on that basic income jam asap.
Unless you want a
revolution for more info,
check out the links down below and please
subscribe for more ml videos. For now,
I've got to go fix a memory leak,
so thanks for watching.